8 news now reporter kate houston shows
us how a part of that effort
will focus on apprenticeship programs
i'm inside the plumbing course at ua
local 525 where second year apprentices
are hard at work governor sissel act
says programs such as this
will be vital to build up nevada's
workforce through its five-year program
the union will certify hundreds of
apprentices in plumbing
pipe fitting welding and hvac governor
sisilak says
this is a great alternative for those
who don't want a traditional college
degree when i'm out there and i'm
watching them whether it's in the
where they're hanging the pipe or the
welding or whatever it might be these
are a lot of young folks that this is
their best opportunity
to move forward it's not easy i don't
think that this is easy it's a long
program to get through it all
as the state faces a challenging
economic recovery
local 525 training director dale
stubblefield says there's also a lack of
qualified workers
blue collar workers are a tremendous
shortage blue collar workers make a ton
of money
i have guys that come in here that apply
for my apprenticeship that are in their
mid-40s
doing a career change they were computer
techs they were this they were that
they can't they can't get a job to help
rebuild the workforce governor sisilak
wants pre-apprenticeship to be more
accessible for high school students
he also wants to better promote existing
programs within community colleges
you get to earn while you're learning
and you get on the job and you're
learning firsthand you can learn so much
out of a book
and part of this is book learning but
part of it is hands on
skill craftsman learning and that you
can only do by one generation passing it
on next generation
governor sysolak is now creating the
nevada job force
where the state's top companies will
design and implement new training
programs
kate houston 8 news now